in this lesson from free pilot training
we'll be discussing the pedostatic
instruments and we'll explain how those
work
in the last few lessons we've been
discussing the gyroscopic instruments
but today we're going to talk about
three of those primary flight
instruments that use air pressure to
give us information these are the air
speed indicator the altimeter and the
vertical speed indicator these
instruments are provided air pressure
from the pitot tube and the static port
and they turn it into information that's
really important for pilots in flight
there are three types of air pressure
that come into play when we talk about
these instruments static air pressure
dynamic air pressure and total air
pressure
static pressure which is also called
ambient air pressure is pressure that's
caused by our atmosphere
this is always present whether the
airplane is stopped or moving
and although it might seem unnoticeable
to you these air molecules push on
everything in our atmosphere
the closer you are to the center of the
earth the more tightly these air
molecules are packed and because they're
packed so tightly at lower elevations
the lower your altitude the higher your
static air pressure is and our airplanes
use static ports to sense this type of
air pressure these are usually placed on
the side so they're not affected by
relative wind static air pressure is
measured in inches of mercury on a
normal standard day at sea level the
average air pressure is 29.92 inches of
mercury now the air pressure isn't
always 29.92 inches of mercury there but
this is about the average so this is
what we call standard air pressure
then every thousand feet above sea level
the pressure reduces by one inch of
mercury in the next lesson we're going
to go into a lot more detail about this
and how the altimeter works so if you
haven't already subscribed please
consider doing so
now anytime an object like an airplane
moves through the air it's impacted by
the air molecules that is traveling
through and this creates a certain
amount of pressure on the object that's
equal and opposite to the airplane's
direction of travel and this is called
dynamic air pressure and in order to
understand how the pedostatic system
works you have to understand that this
pressure is directly related to the
speed at which the aircraft is flying
next we have the total air pressure
and this is a combination of dynamic and
static air pressure and while this may
seem obvious at first you'll see why we
talk about this here in just a minute
now the altimeter uses a static port to
sense the static pressure outside the
aircraft and because the static pressure
changes one inch of mercury every
thousand feet the altimeter is able to
give us an altitude reading because it
senses that pressure now as i mentioned
before static ports are placed on the
side of aircraft
and this keeps the instruments from
being affected by dynamic air pressure
and this keeps the readings as accurate
as possible
the other instrument that uses a static
port is the vertical speed indicator
this instrument allows air to escape or
come in through a small hole which is
vented through the static port
by allowing air to come in or go out
this instrument senses the pressure
differences as we climb or descend then
it gives us a reading in feet per minute
the airspeed indicator is a little bit
different animal it also receives air
from the static pore but not for reasons
you might think
the airspeed indicator measures the ram
air that comes from relative wind
through the pitot tube but this doesn't
give us an accurate measurement because
static air actually makes its way into
the pitot tube as well and this is that
total air pressure we were talking about
earlier
and by taking static air from the static
port the air speed indicator is able to
offset any static air that might come in
through the pitot tube
to keep the air speed indicator as
accurate as possible the people who
designed your airplane usually put the
pitot tube in a spot where it won't be
affected by the prop wash but there is
something that can affect your airspeed
indicator and that's the angle of the
pitot tube in relation to the relative
wind
high angles of attack and different
airplane configurations can affect the
accuracy of your airspeed indicator
and that's because weird angles can make
it difficult for the ram air to enter
the pitot tube
every airplane is different but every
airplane has some kind of error caused
by this and the manufacturers account
for this by putting a chart in the poh
this is what we call calibrated air
speed once you make these corrections
using these charts
something else you could run into that
would cause these instruments to get
errors is if the pitot tube or the
static port got clogged up and there's a
lot of different things that could clog
up these things anything from bugs mud
ice and that's just to name a few one
thing that shouldn't clog up your pitot
tube though is water that's because of
this little drain hole here on the back
i call this the weeping hole this is
there so if water enters the front of
your pitot tube it'll just slide right
out the back here
but if the water freezes in or on the
pitot tube then it can start clogging it
up again but that's what these little
heating elements are for you just turn
the pedo heat on in your cockpit and it
should heat these up enough to melt that
ice
so what happens if these things get
clogged well if the pedo2 gets clogged
the only instrument that's going to be
affected is your airspeed indicator and
if you remember that's because this is
the only instrument that uses dynamic
air pressure to give us a reading for
the airspeed indicator three possible
problems could happen the first would be
if the hole in the front of the pitot
tube for the ram air got clogged
as long as your drain hole doesn't get
clogged what will happen is your air
speed will drop to zero and that's
because the pitot tube is no longer
taking in ram air but the static port
and the drain hole are still both taking
in static air which allow them to offset
each other the second possibility is if
the front of the pitot tube and the
drain hole gets clogged
if this happens any air pressure in the
pitot system will be trapped and your
air speed indicator is frozen at the
last indication it was giving you
from here if the static port is also
plugged you won't see any change but if
the static port is clear then the
airspeed indicator will make minor
changes with altitude i like to tell
students that your airspeed indicator
just turned into an altimeter at this
point the third thing that could
possibly happen is only the static port
gets clogged if this happens the pitot
tube is still taking in the dynamic and
the static pressure from the front of
the pitot tube but the static port is
unable to offset that static air that's
also coming in the front and this means
that your airspeed indicator is going to
give you faster air speeds than what
you're actually going
now because the altimeter and the
vertical speed indicator both use a
static board to get their information if
this gets clogged it's going to affect
both of those too for the altimeter if
the static port gets clogged it's going
to freeze at the last altitude that it
was indicating but the vertical speed
indicator will only display 0 because it
can no longer sense a climb or a descent
if you're lucky enough to have a clogged
static port i do have some good news for
you though on most newer training
airplanes they have something called an
alternate static source
typically this is an alternate static
port that's on the inside of your
cockpit and you can select this
alternate static port by flipping a
switch labeled alternate static on most
airplanes just keep in mind when you use
this alternate static source it's not
quite as accurate as the one on the
outside of the airplane and that's
because the pressure difference on the
inside of the cab is slightly different
than outside now if you don't have an
alternate static source one thing you
can do is you can break the glass on any
of the static instruments
if you do this i recommend breaking the
glass on the vertical speed indicator
and that's because it's by far the least
important of the instruments
and once again if you do this this is
nowhere nearly as accurate as a static
port on the outside of the airplane but
something is better than nothing and in
an emergency this could save your life i
hope you enjoyed today's video if you
did would you click that like button for
me
also if you're really enjoying this
training from the free pilot training
channel be sure to check out our t-shirt
store in the description below then
watch this video right here you know you
want to